are you 54 and thinking that you're
wrapped up because you have 24 year old
children and you've decided that all the
dreams you had are over and you couldn't
accomplish them you haven't even [__]
started and I know the comments are
going to come in and be like what the
[__] are you talking about here's what
I'm talking about you have 30 remarkable
[__] years of execution in front of
you we live in a world now where 54 year
olds can take advantage of this just as
much as 13 year olds and instead of
dwelling of what you have not
accomplished how you [__] up that
marriage took that wrong job went to the
wrong school please step up change your
perspective right now what you've done
over the last 600 plus months means
nothing when it comes to what you're
about to do with the rest of your life
especially when you factor in you have
54 years of knowing what not to do why
don't you spend the next 30 doing the
other [__]